good to see you out here this is this is
like when you get biggest events of the
year and and great because it's such an
important one right yeah so what are you
feeling from this crowd they know the
issues that need to be tackled in the
world how do you get inspiration from
them I do of course yeah one of the
reasons that I love coming to we day is
so much just because of like that
positive aura that is here when you you
can just like see people wanting to make
a change they're all in one area you can
talk to them figure out you know with
their life experience like it's it's
just the most crazy event for you know
just making a change and wanting to be
positive Sylar yeah and how have you
yourself have been impacted because
you've been going on for years now
yeah everybody knows about this how have
you been impacted by the work that they
do I think this is my my 12.we day and
every time I meet people and I'm like I
could never be as good as you you know
so I think it's just inspired me to
become better it just be as best the
best that I can be just and why is we so
much stronger than just me well I mean
two heads together it's better than one
so I don't know it I think everything
when you do things together you do you
work as a team and it's efficient
everything kind of multiplies you get so
much more done it's better work
yeah cheers buddy Kristen you always
you